je vous propose de rester du côté franc
comtois ont posé nos valises maintenant
à morteau le temps semble s'être arrêté
au château pertusier construit il ya
plus de quatre siècles il accueille
depuis quelques années le musée de
l'horlogerie rejoignons tout de suite
notre guide grégory moga il est en
direct et en duplex de besançon
bonjour et bienvenue alors je le disais
le château pertusier du nom de ces
derniers propriétaires est l'un des
rares témoins de l'architecturé
renaissance dans le haut doubs pour
connaître un peu nu sans histoire je
vous propose de regarder ce reportage
puis après on va en parler c'est une
demeure à part qui semble en permanence
lutter contre le temps mais aussi la
différence des hommes
et pourtant malgré une vue directe sur
les panneaux publicitaires comme sur
l'incessant trafic frontalier le château
pertusier qui porte le nom de ces
derniers propriétaire conserve
curieusement une vraie part de mystère
pour un homme une femme entier colonies
il ya des traces de balles aulas vous
avez tout éclat quand l année du sacre à
lima en 1639 ça se caler dans le haut
doubs et il ya eu une bagarre monstres
et cie au pont où il a lu à peu près 700
victimes depuis longtemps riz les airs
s'intéresse à l'histoire de morteau et à
ce lieu construit il ya quatre cent
quarante ans par une riche famille
suisse
photo déjà c'est une seigneurie
ecclésiastique accueillir et commander
tous les vols de motos donc il n'ya pas
de décompte n'est pas par un ehpad de
gens comme ça ici dans la région et
c'est vrai que ce château toujours été
la propriété de riches marchande de
riches possédants mais qui n'avait pas
de quartiers de noblesse
mais ce qui fait aujourd'hui l'intérêt
de ce château qui appartient la ville de
morteau depuis les années 30
c'est qu'il abrite un musée de
l'horlogerie mais si vous avez une pièce
à remontage automatique ou bouger le
bras
cette époque là se balance et ça remonte
on n'a pas de fils et sa personne tout
le temps quand on bouge suffisamment
patiemment collectés depuis les années
80 alors pareil la fée vous regarder ses
cartes et a laissé horloge attire chaque
été de nombreux visiteurs en quête
d'histoires vous faisait plaisir à
chaque fois redécouvrir peut-être des
pièces dans le jeu à découvrir aussi à
entendre les explications montrent et
démontrent le chausson
c'est sympathique je trouve que c'est
une belle collection nom de rien une
visite visite agréable pour les
responsables du musée
le château qui a aussi survécu aux
incendies reste un endroit vraiment
surprenant une fois il ya eu des
visiteurs c'était des descendants des
percus vié
mais il savait même pas trop l'histoire
de la famille apparemment je crois qu'il
était au brésil
autrement non c'est un peu le problème
de ces maisons parce que l'on sait pas
l'histoire des aménagements qu'elle est
l'intérieur une part de mystère
on vit avec
ce château de la renaissance est
aujourd'hui unique dans le haut doubs et
comme d'autres en rivière espérance je
rends percer les secrets
quand on compare leur steak tulle du
palais grand-mère deux ensembles rapport
ce bâtiment ici si on s'aperçoit que
c'est vraiment de la dentelle lapierre
six cultes précédent sur la période 2000
2010 il ya une accumulation de détails
soient menées des sites à un bonbon
renaissance ou non
dans cet écrin on a vu donc on a pu
apercevoir pardon différentes pièces
d'horlogerie est-ce que vous en avez
beaucoup oui on a beaucoup de choses et
puis c'est une collection qui est très
varié donc je pense qu'on n'a pas loin
de 2000 objets avec de la mécanique et
puis des montres anciennes ans quand
vous dites que c'est très varié c'est à
dire on va de l'outil utilisé par
l'horloger pour fabriquer les composants
et puis on va jusqu'aux horloge de
différentes époques louis xiv ou et 15
régence des objets astronomiques
et puis des croates bien sûr est-ce
qu'il avait personne
il ya des pièces uniques où il ya
notamment le verrou nomique réalisé par
un paysan horloger de la région mouthe
donc c'est vraiment la pièce maîtresse
du musée et qu'on est fier de présenter
à des gens des visiteurs de quasiment du
monde entier un paysan lé pas qui a fait
ça par l'âge mais oui c'est ce qui
impressionne beaucoup les visiteurs
c'est que quelqu'un qui avait pas à très
haut niveau d'étude de fabriquer une
pièce astronomique avec une aiguille qui
a fait un tour en un siècle
donc voila quand on compare par rapport
au ps astronomique de strasbourg de
besançon de beauvais fait par des
maîtres horlogers donc là un autre
paysan et a fait un très très bon j'ai
de vraies c'est une façon de la
précision des projets de l'époque
ah bah oui on se rend compte que les
horlogers du xviie xviiie siècle ont
inventé des principes qui sont encore
utilisés actuellement qu'on améliore
énormément mais les principes restent
souvent les mêmes
donc c'est ce qui surprend beaucoup les
visiteurs c'est l'aspect technique et
puis esthétique qui est toujours
remarquable quand vous parlez à
d'esthétisme via également à verser ces
lieux cet écran dans lequel se trouve le
musée est ce qu'il ya des pièces
particulières qui donne une ambiance
je dirais que tout tout tout battez mort
d'une ambiance particulière dans le
musée on a sept salles d'exposition
autres au rez-de-chaussée où là c'est
plutôt une ambiance pierre un peu plus
sombre et puis l étage on a des grandes
fenêtres des boiseries
donc on a une autre ambiance de luminosa
depuis trente ans ces trente dernières
années vont cesser d'enrichir votre
collection avez vous récemment acquis de
nouvelles pièces oui bah écoutez j'ai
cherché deux pièces mardi prochain à
pontarlier il ya un monsieur qui nous
donne deux horloges
donc voilà c'est des belles pièces avec
techniquement impeccable puis qui vont
bien compléter un petit peu les
collections du musée donc je dirais que
musée ne rime pas forcément avec figé on
complète régulièrement les collections
et à connaître un peu l'histoire de
presque tout c'est peut-être ça c'est le
problème c'est qu'on sait pas forcément
l'histoire de chaque pièce ça ce qui est
dommage parce que derrière chaque objet
il ya une histoire mais par exemple la
personne qui donne ces deux horloges la
semaine prochaine il lui est demandé de
rédiger un petit article sur ces pièces
de famille donc c'est intéressant de
savoir ça et puis après une fois les
gages d une montre et puis on a
découvert à l'intérieur
un petit bout de papier avec l'histoire
de cette montre donc c'est toujours
émouvant de retrouver ça malheureusement
merci beaucoup de nous avoir parlé donc
du musée de l'horlogerie à morteau qui
est devenu d'ailleurs un endroit
incontournable pour les visites dans
notre région merci à vous et donc je
rappelle que ce musée est ouvert toute
la semaine et pour des visites guidées
et bien il suffit de demander